[MUSIC PLAYING]
-It's really a pleasure to
introduce Robin Cotton to you.
She is a molecular
biologist and biochemist
who is going to talk about
forensic DNA testing.
She's now associate
professor and director
of the Biomedical
Forensic Program
at BU School of Medicine.
Dr. Cotton's experience
with forensic DNA
began at Selmark
Diagnostics back in 1988
and she served as the lab
director for the Selmark lab
from 1994 to 2006.
In that position
and since, she's
served in a number
of high profile cases
around the country.
She's been an expert
witness in DNA cases,
about 200 cases in just about
every state in our nation.
She also oversees the
development and implementation
of new techniques
for using the lab,
as well as participating
in this casework
and testifying in court.
She is an elected
member of the board
of directors of the American
Society of Crime Lab Directors
and the lab accreditation
board for a four-year term
and is, as I said, now director
of the Biomedical Forensic
Sciences Program at BU.
So please welcome
Dr. Robin Cotton.
[APPLAUSE]
-Well, I hope my voice is good.
There we go.
I want to thank the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study
for putting on such
a wonderful series
because I got to
come to the symposium
and it was, if you didn't
get there, really wonderful.
And I would really like
to thank all of you.
I'm amazed to see
so many people who
came out on a super
cold, snowy night
to hear about forensic science.
So we'll talk about
that for a little bit
and we'll give you a
little bit of background.
It's not going to
be hugely in depth
because we don't
have time to do that.
And then I'm going to see if
I can discuss with you some
of the things that are
difficult about what we do
and some of the things that
are difficult about what
we do just because
we're interacting
with the legal system.
I came to forensic science
almost by accident.
I left a very nice, comfortable
post-doc at NIH in 1988
and went to work for a small,
private laboratory that
was in Germantown, Maryland,
a little ways up the road.
At least the traffic
was going this way
and I was going that way.
That was probably
the best thing.
And I worried about
that for a long time
because I had left the
strictly research environment.
And after a couple of
years of worrying about it,
I never looked back.
And apart from my wonderful
choice of a life partner, that
is the best decision I made.
It turns out that doing
the same thing all the time
can be challenging and fun in
ways that you wouldn't imagine.
Now, these look
like maybe pictures.
We're all seeing crime scene
and forensic people on the TV
all the time.
These are actually pictures
of our students at BU.
We do use lovely blue lights
as alternate light sources
to identify where there might
be a blood stain or a semen
stain or something else.
People do stand around behind
crime scene tape trying
to figure out how they're
going to approach whatever's
going on.
And that's our field space,
which is over in Holliston.
And evidence does arrive in
labs in little brown bags
with evidence tape
on them indicating
who opened it on what date
and what part of the package
was opened.
So all of that stuff
is real, but most
of the rest of the
stuff that you see on TV
is kind of not real or edgy.
It could be very edgy, right?
So this slide is here
just to give you an idea
and give me a way to talk about
forensic science in general.
The National
Institutes of Standards
has recently convened about
500 forensic scientists
and academic experts to
begin to write standards
for all of these activities.
So you see on your right
is biology and DNA,
and there we have biological
methods, which includes
DNA and interpretation of data.
And we also have
wildlife forensics,
which is usually species
identification, but not
always through DNA.
And so that little wedge is the
thing I know something about.
At BU, we also teach
the chemistry things
which are explosive; firearms;
trace evidence, which is really
material science
applications; seized drugs,
which are is this powdered sugar
or is it cocaine or something
worse; and toxicology, what
does this person who didn't
make it have in their body?
So those disciplines
we work with at BU
and we also teach
crime scene and a lot
of general criminalistics.
There are, however,
these other things
that are very important to
regular forensic laboratories.
One is digital and multimedia,
like what does this guy have
on his computer and
when did it get there
and what was he doing with it?
And there's also pattern
evidence, fingerprints,
comparisons of tool marks,
tire tracks, footwear,
things like that.
And some of these disciplines
are not as sciencey
as we would like them to be
and that will be a big part.
So right at the moment, DNA
does have standards and crime
labs have standards.
We'll come to another slide
about that in a second.
But technical standards
currently do not exist.
There are guidelines in
some of these disciplines,
but not standards.
So this activity at NIST with
this 500 or so people divided
up into all these
different areas
is to write technical standards.
And in our case
of DNA, we will be
writing additional technical
standards, which are needed.
So just as, again, an
overview, most forensic labs
are publicly funded.
So in Massachusetts, you have
the Massachusetts State Police
Crime Laboratory, which
is under the umbrella
of the Massachusetts
State Police.
And you have the Boston Police
Department Crime Laboratory,
which is under the umbrella of
the Boston Police Department.
In addition to publicly
funded laboratories,
there are private
laboratories-- ones
that do DNA, ones
that do toxicology,
ones that do digital
evidence, and others
around the country that
may have other specialties.
And in addition to that, there
are private practitioners
and consultants who are also
active in the forensic arena.
And that kind of covers your
group and where they work.
The position of
crime laboratories
under law enforcement
agencies is currently
being hotly debated.
However, if you say, well, we
have a big pool of people here
who think that they shouldn't be
under law enforcement agencies,
wedging them out from
under the law enforcement
agency is a whole other
story because then you're
into politics and
people don't like
to give up the things
that they control, right?
So if that's the
direction we should go,
it's not going to
happen very fast.
Now, another really good thing
is that most-- it's not 100%,
but it's close to all-- crime
laboratories are accredited.
There are about four
accrediting bodies in the US.
They all accredit to the
international standard ISO/IEC
2.7025.
Most of them have some
supplemental standards
that are specific to
forensic science like how
do you collect the
evidence, how do you keep
a proper chain of custody, how
do you write a proper report,
things like that that are
different for forensic science
than for some other activities.
And as I said a few
minutes ago, right now only
DNA and forensic biology
have technical standards
that are required, and
that is because there
is overarching national
legislation from 1994 that
allows the FBI to have a
convicted felon database.
And that database is
managed by the FBI,
and only if the lab is
accredited and meets
these technical
standards is the lab
allowed to put either evidence
or convicted felon profiles up
to the database.
Now, I don't have any slides
about that database here,
but it's very, very
powerful because it really
consists of multiple databases.
But the two major ones
are convicted offenders
in one pile over
here, of which there
are around 11 million profiles.
So we're not talking some
little tiny data set.
And then over here
are the case profiles.
These are case
profiles from evidence.
And so if there's a
case that comes up,
it can be searched against
the offender database.
If a match is made,
then that's a huge lead.
If no match is
made, it can still
be compared to the
other case profiles.
And if it matches some
other case profile,
then you can connect
two cases and then
these two police agencies
can get together, exchange
information, and possibly
come to a faster solution
for that particular case.
Now, we'll leave general
forensics for a moment.
Let's talk about forensic DNA.
In 1985, there were
two papers published
that really give us the tools
that we're currently using.
The first of those
papers was published
by Alec Jeffreys,
who's now Sir Alec
Jeffreys from the
University of Leicester.
And he had one of
those aha moments
that scientists
sometimes get to have
where he gets off this
autorad, this x-ray film
from his experiment, and
looks at it and goes,
I don't know what went wrong.
And then has the aha moment
of everybody on this film has
a different banding pattern.
We're visualizing the first
individualization of humans
across all the people
that I have on this thing.
It was a fabulous thing
because I've done research,
I know a lot of researchers,
and a lot of stuff
like that just
goes in the trash.
And you just go oh, it didn't
work, let me do that again.
And he didn't.
In the same year, Kary
Mullis discovers PCR,
develops the method for
PCR, which revolutionized
all of diagnostics, all
of molecular biology,
and for which he received the
Nobel Prize not too long after
that because it was
such an important tool
and allows us to identify some
specific segment of DNA we
would like to copy, copy
it in an exponential form.
So from two copies you
end up with millions
and then you have enough
mass of this material
to actually do some chemistry
with it or test it in some way.
These two things did not
come together in forensics
until the late 1990s,
with our current testing.
But Jeffreys' discovery was the
basis for the early testing,
and that was RFLP testing.
So what you're looking
at here came from my lab.
This is a film that was part
of the evidence in the Simpson
trial.
And so you're looking at
these banding patterns.
This is the top of the gel
and the DNA migrated down
according to size and
then the sequences
are identified
through hybridization
with radioactive probes.
It's been a time since I had
to talk about one of these.
But these were wonderful to take
to court because a six-year-old
can do this, right?
So here's one known right
here, here's another known,
and here's another known.
And here's our evidence.
Which one does it match?
It matches known number two.
The evidence in this
case is DNA that
was extracted from a blood stain
on socks in Simpson's residence
and known number
two is Nicole Brown.
So it's easy.
You couldn't explain
it, it's not too hard.
But that was then, right?
Now we have short
tandem repeats.
And what we're
testing are 16 loci
and soon the labs will
move to testing 22.
So the FBI sort of
decides on the panel,
companies make
the kits that have
the primers and the
[? TAC ?] and the everything
to do the amplification.
And what we're doing
with all these loci
are looking at variation
in the number of repeats
that we have in our DNA.
So in this case, this
allele has six repeats;
this allele has nine; the
genotype for this locus
is a 6-9.
It's nice to see in the diagram.
In reality, we're
looking at this.
So the x-axis here
is molecular weight.
So this is a locus
where the alleles have
been made by virtue of choosing
the primers to be smaller
in length.
This is longer.
And this y-axis is the
height of the peak.
Now, the peak heights are
informative and sort of not
perfectly quantitative, but
relatively quantitative,
which I don't have
time to show you later.
But that does become
important when
you're looking at mixtures.
And so we have four loci here.
This one's heterozygous,
heterozygous, homozygous,
heterozygous.
And then all these
four are heterozygous
and this one is also.
So that's what the
current data looks like.
This is half of a profile,
but I wanted to make it big
so it would be easy to see.
And you might notice that
at this locus right here,
the two peaks are
approximately equal in height.
That's a good thing,
that's what we expect.
We have one copy of each allele.
We would like them to PCR
exactly the same amount
and give us the same height.
But we have these other loci
where the heights of the peaks
are not equal, and this
is mainly a problem
with the PCR reaction.
It's more of a
problem when you're
using very small
amounts of DNA and less
of a problem with
larger amounts.
But what it means is
we have to understand
how big those
differences might be so
that we know when we're sort
of past the normal differences
when we analyze data.
And so that's the data
that's coming down the pike.
So the process goes like
this, and we're going
to have two slides of process.
But ultimately, if you don't
care about the process,
you know that you get a
profile out at the end.
So first of all, evidence
is found at the scene
and the scene is messy.
Now, I'm not a
crime scene person.
In fact, I probably
shouldn't tell you
this because you won't
think it's so interesting,
but I've not been
into a crime scene
because they're not happy
events and I never was really
sure that I wanted to go there.
Just knowing something
about the evidence
felt like that was enough to me.
It's like physicians,
you don't want
to know too much because having
the mentality that you're
going to get the bad guy is not
the mentality that you want.
You need to look at that
data in an unbiased manner,
and so for me I was
never-- I don't want to go,
I'm happy with my position.
So evidence is collected at the
scene, brought into the lab,
and then you have to
find well, does it
have biological material on it?
And so there are relatively
fast-acting chemical tests that
turn a color or turn
black or something
that says I
presumptively have blood
or I definitely have
blood or I may have semen
or I definitely have semen.
And semen, of
course, is ultimately
identified microscopically
because you're
going to see sperm.
And so at that
point, then you're
going to take a sample
from that evidence.
You would always like to save
some portion of that evidence
for later testing.
Because if you
don't get anything,
maybe you didn't do a very
good job and somebody else
is going to try or maybe you
don't have the right technology
today but you're going to have
the right technology in five
years.
If you think about the
RFLP film that I showed you
a few minutes ago, that took
about 500 times more DNA
than what we can do today.
So if you didn't test it with
RFLP and you hung onto it,
you can test it now.
So then the DNA gets
purified from the evidence
in some manner, goes through
a PCR-based procedure
to say how much
human DNA do I have?
Because of course, these
are not nice, clean samples.
I used to think-- everybody
in forensic thinks,
oh, we're the only people who
have all these messy samples.
But that's not true because
people in water quality
and all kinds of
other disciplines
have really disgusting
samples, as well.
And so I keep telling
the forensic people,
you're not the only ones,
other people do this, too.
And in fact, that's
important because there's
information in that literature
that helps people figure out
how to get rid of inhibitors
or other things are a problem.
So anyway, then you
PCR amplify your DNA,
run your capillary
electrophoresis,
and get your profile.
And now you're all happy,
you have your profile.
And now there is a protocol
and a set of things
that you want to do
to think about how
to interpret this protocol.
And we're not going to
spend a lot of time here,
but first you have to
recognize what's a peak
and what's an artifact.
There are artifacts
in the PCR, there
are artifacts in the
capillary electrophoresis.
Most of those are
very easily diagnosed.
You have to understand
when is your PCR
telling that you may
have lost some data.
If you think about that allele
that was really short compared
to the taller one
it was next to,
if it got much shorter it
might join the signal that
was at the baseline, right?
So you can
occasionally lose data,
depending on the amount of
DNA that you started with.
And then you have to think
about how many contributors do I
have in this profile?
It's very easy to
define when you
have a single source profile,
which is what we looked at.
It's more difficult if you
have two, but it's doable.
If you have three or
four contributors,
you have now reached a
mathematically complicated
problem.
So we'll talk about that
a little in a little bit.
And at the and, if you are
including a known individual
as a possible contributor
to an evidence profile,
you are required by law and
by the accreditation standards
to put a numerical
weight to that.
Is that likely to happen
because that profile occurs
in 100 individuals?
Sort of like blood types, right?
Think about testing with blood
types-- 60% percent of us
sort of have O, so they
would have included you
if you had O. And
then you're like,
well, wait, tons of people have
O. But you're still included,
right?
So you have to put some
weight to that profile.
Does that profile occur in
one in 100 million or 100
billion individuals?
Well, then that match
is pretty meaningful.
But you cannot just say, the
person is included because that
inclusion could range from
range from being included at one
or two loci in a profile, where
that's all the data you have,
or it could be an inclusion
at 16 or 15 loci in a single
source profile, where no one
else on Earth is likely to have
that profile, except, of
course, always identical twins.
So in any case.
So I want to talk Just briefly
about persistent challenges
that we have.
And one of the first ones
sounds like, well, this
shouldn't be hard, right?
Recovery of cells from
substrates and the efficiency
of the recovery
of DNA from cells.
If we walk into this
room and there's
a blood stain over there
on the yellow wall,
how are we going to
get those cells off?
Basically, people wet
a swab and swab it.
Well, that doesn't
get them all off.
I mean the more
cells we get off,
the higher the amount of
DNA we're going to have
and the more likely
we can get a result.
So removing cells from a
substrate-- it might be a wall,
it might be a vaginal
swab, it might
be something else-- it matters.
And cells, it turns out when
they're all dried on there,
they really don't
like to let go.
And then we have this
balance in DNA efficiency.
You can get all the DNA
but it's not really clean,
or you can get a portion of
the DNA but it's really clean.
And bringing those
things sort of more
together would be a good
idea and is something people
are working on.
But those tools actually
can still be improved.
We need consistent and
accurate interpretation
of profile results when we
have very low amounts of DNA.
And it turns out
that can be tricky.
And then we need prevention
of contamination.
And I have a story to
go along with that,
which is not particularly
a good story,
so not occurring
in Massachusetts.
Triple homicide in a home.
A defendant is
charged and convicted
and in prison on death row.
Now, I don't know whether
this man is guilty
or not but the scenario
is that some DNA testing
was done in 1999 with STRs.
It's not super powerful, but
he visited this home the night
before the homicide.
So now you don't know is
DNA there because he visited
or because he did something?
So one of the weapons was a cast
iron skillet which broke apart.
That's how hard it was used.
So the handle of
that skillet was not
tested in the original testing.
So now the case is going
through all the court
proceedings and appeals that
go with a death sentence.
And in 2005-ish, they decide to
test the handle of the skillet.
They test the handle
of the skillet.
The handle of the skillet
comes up with a single source
male profile.
And the defendant's attorneys
and the other people are going,
I don't know.
Anyway, so they compare that
to the database, no match.
And they do something
that they should do,
and they were careful,
and they said, well,
we need to allow other people.
So they test the lab people.
In fact, almost all
labs know the profiles
of the people working
there, which you can imagine
would be important for
chasing down contamination.
It's not the lab people.
The single source profile
on the handle of the skillet
was consistent with
the court reporter.
The court reporter and others
in the courtroom handled
the evidence during the trial,
and now what you have is
evidence that you cannot
retest, or even if you retest it
and get something, that
something is suspect.
I mean for people who were are
really looking for the answer,
it just kills you because your
opportunity for that answer
because they didn't
know-- I mean it's '99,
they should have known
but they didn't do it.
They didn't do it right.
So all of those things matter.
Now, if we go back up one
second to this consistent bit,
we know this is also a problem.
Because the National
Institute of Standards
sent some complicated mixture
profiles out to a lot of labs--
not the evidence, just
the paper profiles
like the green and blue
one we saw a while ago--
and asked the labs to
use their own protocol.
So they had evidence and
some fake known people.
They asked the lab to compare
the evidence to the knowns
and write a report.
In the best of all
possible worlds,
right, they would get back the
same report from every lab.
No, they did not.
Not only that, in some
labs there were different
reports within the lab.
So now we really have a problem.
So I'm going to-- oh, one slide.
So this is just a
way to say, this
is the contamination issue.
In my lab at BU, I
had a student who
picked off the microscope stage
10 cells, put them in a tube.
We put in some reagents,
didn't really clean it up any.
We can easily
reproducably get a profile
from 10 cells in a
perfect clean scenario.
Typically, you're going
to use a nanogram or so,
but think about what
happens if you have
four people in that nanoram.
Now you're sort of
at low amounts of DNA
for all those four people.
You don't know in advance how
many contributors there are.
You can't know that.
You can see it when
you get the profile,
but you can't see it when
you're handling the evidence.
Let's say you had
a sexual assault
and there was a
consensual partner.
Then you might say, well,
it's likely I might see three.
But there are procedures for
trying to separate out sperm
from the other cell types
that are in that evidence.
Those procedures
are pretty good.
So maybe in your sperm
fraction, you might have two
and maybe you can manage that.
But you never know ahead of
time what you're going to get.
So let's think
about-- these are just
kind of slightly weird
cartoons, but they're meant
to make a very important point.
If I have one
contributor, one person,
I'm going to either have two
alleles that are the same,
that person will be homozygous,
I'll see a single peak,
or they'll have two different
alleles, they're heterozygous,
I see two peaks.
That is not difficult
to figure out.
That's as easy as the
Simpson [INAUDIBLE].
If I have two contributors,
I might have one peak
if both people are
homozygous for the same peak.
I might have two,
three, or four.
This is half of the
combinations that you
could have because you have
to just reverse them, right?
So all together, there
14 ways that I can mix up
the alleles of two
people for each
locus to get one, two,
three, or four peaks.
Now, you can in
most circumstances
kind of sort that out
because you might also
have more of one
person than the other,
so the peak heights
of one person
may be higher than the other,
than the second person.
And so in a lot of circumstances
you configure that out.
OK, great.
What happens when
you go to three?
Here is what happens
when you go to three.
And these are just
sort of the basics.
All together, there
are 150 combinations
of ways that you can put alleles
from three people together
to get one, two, three,
four, five, or six peaks.
You cannot sort this out
by staring at the profile.
No amount of staring
at the profile
is going to let this
come into your head.
And yet, my lab
and other labs have
been trying to do this by
hand for a very long time.
The concern is-- now,
I don't have a lab
anymore so hopefully I would
have fixed it by now, right--
but the concern is that when
people-- so this is just three,
imagine four, right?
That gets even worse.
And if somebody in
here is a mathematician
and you have a graduate
student and you
want them to do a cool problem,
I have a problem for you
because nobody
has really figured
out how many permutation
combinations there
are for four.
Somebody tried,
but they gave up.
I know there's a proper
math way to do that,
but I tried it and
I couldn't do it.
In any case, now
I want to tell you
a very short-- I'll try to make
it short-- story about this.
And that is let's imagine
we have the six alleles
and we're just going to call
them one, two, three, four,
five, six.
And let's imagine
that the defendant
has alleles one and six.
Well, that profile has
alleles one and six, right?
But as it's pictured, nobody
in that particular combination
has the genotype one in six.
It's the genotype that matters,
not whether the alleles are
present.
And that's what you cannot
decipher when you have three
contributors.
And I was reading a transcript
a couple of years ago,
and the transcript was not good.
And the witness is
saying in relation
to the defendant and the mixture
profile, his alleles are here.
Now, what does that say?
It sounds like she knows
that the alleles that
are the same between the
profile and the defendant
are actually his.
But she doesn't know that.
He might be a one-six, but she
doesn't know the genotypes that
went to make up that mixture.
So she's saying that, and then
pretty soon the prosecutor
is saying, his alleles are here.
And then on cross-examination,
the defense attorney
starts using that very same
language, his alleles are here.
That is wrong.
That is not OK.
Now every witness
knows that they're
supposed to make things
simple for the jury.
But there's simple and
then there's wrong.
So all right.
Now we're going to leave
this because I'm getting
close to being out of time.
These are new things that
are coming down the pike.
And of these new things,
they're all cool and wonderful.
The most important right
now is the last one,
which is software-- mathematical
modeling software which
is designed to model
the peaks in the profile
and figure out what the
real contributors are.
That software works for
two-person and three-person
and sometimes
four-person mixtures.
It has limitations.
We all know what
those limitations are.
And the implementation of
that software in the last,
I would say, a year and a
half is really picking up.
So of the new things,
that's the most important.
And the others are going
to be very cool toys
and will help out a lot.
But let's move on because
I want to do these things.
You could be as geeky
as you want at school,
but you cannot be that
geeky when you go to court.
It does not work.
Now, there are a lot of
pressures on laboratories,
these are some of them.
Crime laboratories have budgets,
they have personnel issues,
they need to do
high quality work.
The amplification kits,
one kit to run 200 samples,
costs $4,000.
It's not cheap to do this work.
And when sequencing
comes along, which it is,
it's going to be
even more expensive.
There is no requirement
for anything
other than a Bachelor
of Science degree
if you want to do
this work, unless you
want to be a technical
leader, in which case
you need a master's degree,
which sometimes when
I'm granting somebody
a degree I'm going,
oh my God, please don't let that
student be a technical leader.
This one over here, good.
That one over there, maybe not.
Most labs do not have
dedicated research staff,
and so as the very complicated
things come down the pike
they are all going to
have some-- not all,
but a lot of labs-- are
going to have issues.
And some labs are
huge, they have
100 analysts or 50 analysts.
But some labs have four.
And validation is required in
order to put new things online,
so that's important.
Also there's no central
repository for validation data.
There's no requirement
for really serious
continuing education.
You have to have eight hours
per year or something like that.
But you know what happens--
you go to meeting,
you sit for eight hours,
you get as much as you can,
then you go back and you go,
OK, I've got to do my work now.
That isn't staying with you.
We need to have a
better understanding
of how errors happen and how
bias affects our judgment
when we're
interpreting profiles.
And we also, and I have a
great story to go with this but
I'm not going to tell you
because I don't have time.
We need to do a better job
of connecting basic research
with forensic science.
So the quick story was
I had a student who
wanted to work on a procedure
to see if we could get better
recovery of DNA from sperm.
So I sent him to the library.
I said, go off, look at this.
Well, it turns out--
and this is my fault,
I didn't know-- I
mean it turns out
there is massive amounts
of literature on sperm
because people want
to have babies.
I didn't know that massive
amount of literature was there.
I never went and looked at it.
And it turns out
that when you go
look at that and
all the biochemistry
that they now know in
developmental biology of how
sperm come to be has
a lot to do with how
we should extract the DNA.
And now it was just
mind boggling to me
how I had ignored all
that information for such
a long time.
And there are many, many
other examples of that.
There's a lot of research out
there that could be applied,
but those people
don't know anything
abroad forensic science
and the forensic scientists
don't know about that research.
And there's no real vehicle
to get those people together.
There's a guy on
the BU campus who's
doing surface-enhanced Raman
spectroscopy, which I can say
it but I can't do it, right?
It turns out he has a method for
identifying body fluids that he
may be able to make
a portable instrument
and identify body fluids
at the scene and say,
that is a rust spot, but
that is a blood stain.
Let's pick up that
piece of evidence.
I don't even know how he figured
out he might want to do that.
But he called us
up and said, do you
have people who
know these things?
And we're like, oh, yeah,
we have those people.
So forensic science
is very public.
Partly it's because
you're going to court.
So there's the Simpson
trial, the World Trade Center
identifications,
innocence projects,
exonerations very important.
Everybody's probably read about
Annie Dookhan, and thousands
of cases.
She was being helpful to
the police, very productive.
And that lab, I must
say, was not accredited.
And shame on the Massachusetts--
I don't know who it would be.
The crime lab was accredited,
but this lab was not.
So that might not have caught
it at the very beginning,
but at the rate she was doing
that it would have been caught.
So you have good days in court.
Now you've done your
test, you have your data.
How things go doesn't
just depend on you,
but depends on
all these players.
A good attorney on
both sides is worth
a huge amount because
a good attorney knows
what questions to
ask and they should
be asking those questions.
And the witness should be
prepared to answer them.
The witness should be prepared
to not be defensive and treat
the proceedings with respect
and understand their role.
A bad day in court is when
everybody is not prepared,
nobody's really doing their job.
Prosecutors will say to
a witness a, they'll say,
I don't have time
to pre-trial or talk
to you in advance and b, I'll
just ask you a few questions
and you just run with it.
No.
That doesn't work because a,
if the witnesses good they're
still basically on their
own and they may not
know what's most important
to the prosecutor.
You can't wing it on your own.
That is basically
the bottom line.
You can't be defensive.
It's your job to
answer the questions.
And sometimes the
attorneys are obnoxious
and sometimes they yell at you.
I've had attorneys
call me a liar.
Yeah, really.
I mean look at me.
I look nice, right?
It's insulting, but you
have to set that aside
because your role is to
explain what you got.
And if you're all insulted
and you're all defensive,
you're not going to
be able to do that.
It's the jury, it's you guys
out there, that have to decide.
It's my job to tell you
what that data means
and be clear about
what it doesn't mean
so you can't misinterpret it.
Going to court requires
communication skills,
it requires a lot of patience.
You know how on TV it's
always fast and like that?
No.
It is slow as molasses.
And the attorneys stumble
over-- in attorney language year
doing loci.
I don't know why
every attorney thinks
it's called the loci instead
of a low loci, but they do.
You have to have
a lot of patience
and you have to have depth in
your scientific understanding
of what you're doing.
It's not called on all the
time, but when you need it,
it needs to be there.
And communicating science to
non-scientists is difficult.
It takes practice.
In the beginning, I
would write it out
and then I got pretty
comfortable with testifying.
And then we switched to
PCR and I thought, well,
I really understand PCR.
I'll be able to just do it.
And the first time I
testified about PCR,
you would have thought I was
speaking a foreign language.
I mean nothing came out right.
It didn't make any sense.
No person could
have on understood
what I said and I promptly
went home and said,
OK, well you've got to write
this out and practice it
so that it makes some sense.
And sometimes it's just hard.
Lab make mistakes,
people make mistakes.
You have to answer
to those mistakes.
You cannot just go,
it's not my problem.
If you have something
to say and it's not
positive about yourself
or your laboratory,
you just have to say it in a
voice that's matter of fact
and speaking the truth.
So I have one slide, which is
my favorite slide, because it's
a quote from Einstein.
And I think it speaks
to lots of people,
but it especially speaks
to forensic scientists.
The right to search for the
truth implies also a duty;
one must not conceal
any part of what
one has recognized to be true.
If you have an inconclusive
result, that's it.
That's all.
If you're not sure, you say so.
If your lab made a
mistake, you say so.
A good witness will do that.
And it's a privilege to
be able to do this work.
It's fun.
It's nice to do good
science and then find
people who are excited about it
because the lawyers are always
like, this is super cool.
Testifying is mostly OK.
And thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]